in more coveted news the cdc is warning
all americans to avoid travel to japan
because of its latest jump in kobet
cases the advisory will not keep u.s
athletes out of the upcoming tokyo
olympics
but organizers are still under severe
pressure raymino senso reports on
japan's
desperate push to save the games
when tokyo won its bid to host the 2020
summer olympics
japan was ecstatic fast forward to today
and coronavirus is surging across the
country for a fourth time
less than two months before the opening
ceremony a new survey
indicates that the masked majority of
japan more than 8
in 10 people want the games to be
postponed again
or canceled for good people like dance
instructor sauri yamashita
who said she fears the olympics could
cause a surge in covet infections
and another state of emergency that
would force her school to close
tokyo-based political scientist koichi
nakano says that is a real possibility
well it would be possibly a super spread
event that's in part why the state
department is now telling americans in
plain language
do not travel to japan due to covet 19.
of japan's 126 million people only about
2 percent have been fully vaccinated
compare that with nearly 40 percent in
the us
health systems in cities like osaka have
been described as on the brink of
collapse
should the games go on no i think it's
just not
feasible people are sort of upset now
not just with the japanese government
but the
ioc the arrogance in assuming that
japan is uh willing to host in spite of
overwhelming public opinion
against for cbs this morning raimi in
asensio
hong kong